Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Sieh mal, wie sie sich an die Worte anbauen.
Sieh mal, wie sie sich anbauen.
Moment, in diesem System sind doch nur juristische oder private Personen oder Behörden, die nachgewiesen haben, dass sie sozusagen Mails verschicken dürfen und da kann man auch davon ausgehen, dass sie keinen Spam verschicken.
Naja, der Absender ist ein Computer.
Ne, also das muss man schon mal sehr klar sagen. Denn die Adressformate, die wir vorhin genannt haben, die sind vorkonfiguriert. Die lauten immer in derselben Form Vorname Punkt, Nachname Punkt und wenn mehrere Leute gibt dann noch einen Punkt mit einer Nummer dahinter. Also eine Nummerierung der Person. Danach kommt immer ein Etat et Zeichen. Der Anbietername, wir nehmen mal GMX, dann ein Punkt, dann de-strich mehr de. Das heißt, die sind insofern generisch. Das heißt, wir wissen folgendes. Welche Anbieter gibt es? Die sind öffentlich. Die kann man also, die sogenannten Bürgerportals, Dienstanbieter, die sind öffentlich. Die kann ich mir suchen. Und ich kann Teilnehmer, von denen ich Vor- und Zunahme habe, also normale Adresslisten oder Telefonbücher, kann ich mir hernehmen. Damit habe ich generierbare Adressen.
Aber was habe ich denn davon? Weil ihr habt doch vorhin erklärt, ich kann gar keine Medien in das System reinstecken, wenn ich nicht sozusagen auch ein zertifizierter Absender bin.
Und wenn du dich selber registrierst?
Wie selber?
Also das ist ja eine Möglichkeit. Also du kannst ja selber eine De-Mail-Adresse haben.
Oder du könntest die De-Mail-Adresse von jemand anderem benutzen.
Das heißt, es ist wirklich sehr einfach, hier eine valide Adressliste zu haben für Spammer. Das heißt, die Argumentation, dieses ganze System würde gegen Spam helfen, ist doch ausgesprochen fragwürdig. Aber wir haben noch was Lustiges entdeckt, was dem eventuell entgegenwirken könnte. Nämlich, man kann maximal 100 Nachrichten am Tag versenden. Da mussten wir doch lachen drüber.
Und maximal an 300 Leute.
Insofern haben sie eine physische Grenze eingebaut.
Man kann also nicht so viel Spam kriegen.
Ich meine, Spam ist Spam. Soll ich mir nachher noch die Zeit nehmen, denn da auch noch zu sortieren? Beziehungsweise, wer garantiert mir denn, dass die Sachen vom Anbieter nicht auch irgendwie, nicht von mir eingestellt, irgendwie nicht weitergeleitet werden? Oder sind, ohne dass ich das in meinen eigenen Spamfilter gelegt hab, dort abgelegt werden? Und wie ihr sagt, bleiben wir bitte bei der Bestätigung. Die sind eingegangen. Die sind eingegangen. Drei Tage. Ich weiß das nicht. Und meine Fristen laufen.
Naja, also ich seh schon ein, was du von Punkt machen willst. Aber da ist der Anbieter, ich sag mal von der juristischen Seite, natürlich verpflichtet. Das heißt, er würde sich da klar gegen das Gesetz oder gegen die Rechtsverordnung wenden. Das heißt, er hat dann Pflichten, die hat er zu erfüllen. Er kann nicht irgendwas wegfiltern.
Also um es genau zu sagen, am Anfang wurde erklärt, der Anbieter meldet ja an den Absender der De-Mail, die Mail ist bei uns angekommen und liegt jetzt theoretisch beim Nutzer am Postkasten. Das heißt, wenn die Mail im Spam…
Auf Verlangen des Absenders. Also nicht in jedem Fall.
Ach, macht das nicht immer? Genau.
Aber das ist dann auch eine Garantie.
Genau, aber wenn diese Meldung gekommen ist, dann muss sie also sagen, im Briefkasten, also in der Inbox des Empfängers liegen und darf nicht irgendwie in einem Spamfach oder wir stellen dir das vielleicht zu.
Also die Postfach, diese E-Mail hat keine Spam-Unterordner?
Hat es möglicherweise, aber wenn darin eine Mail liegt, zählt das nicht als Laufzeit. Also es zählt erst als eingegangen, wenn es bei dir in der Inbox geht. Also so ist das Konzept.
Naja, wir können nicht sagen, ob tatsächlich ein Spam-Orner angelegt wird. Da es bisher kein System gibt, wo man sich das mal ansehen könnte. Ich halte es für unwahrscheinlich, dass sie, wie bei den Gratismails, bei den Bezahl-Mails auch, einen Spam-Orner überhaupt anlegen. Das kann ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen. Denn da würden sie, es wird vielleicht später mal irgendwann kommen, wenn es sich herausstellt, dass es wirklich Spam gibt, aber am Anfang werden sie sicherlich ihr eigenes Konzept negieren, wenn sie das überhaupt tun. Dennoch ist natürlich vom Aufbau her, der ja wirklich sehr generisch ist, klar, dass diese Adressen sehr einfach zu generieren sind von Spamern. Das fand ich schon ein bisschen lustig, dass die Post jetzt betont, man könnte damit angeblich beim Bekämpfen.
Rainer, beantwortet das jetzt deine Frage?
Nicht so zufriedenstellend, aber das war das. Also auf alle Fälle, ich werde mir keine E-Brief im Postfach zulegen, weil es mir einfach zu unsicher, beziehungsweise noch mehr Daten für einen Staat, die Elenora oder wie das heißt, Plus-E-Brief muss nicht sein. Das war's.
Alles klar. Also Rainer auch dagegen. Ich glaube, es steht jetzt 5 zu 0 oder so.
4 zu 0, ja.
Hörer gegen De-Mail. Falls es draus jemanden gibt, der findet, die De-Mail-Superidee muss ich unbedingt haben. Herzlich willkommen an die Handrufe 0331 70 97 110. Vielleicht gibt es ja ganz gute Gründe, warum das alles total toll ist. Wir haben es einfach noch nicht quasi entdeckt.
Das ist aber ganz schlecht. Auf unserer Liste sind nur Gegengründe noch, die wir noch nennen wollen.
Deswegen sollen ja Leute anrufen, weil möglicherweise habt ihr was übersehen.
Vielleicht seid ihr einfach immer so böse Kritiker, die an nichts was guten lassen.
Wir haben am Anfang ja die Idee, die jetzt hinter dem Konzept steht, die haben wir ja eigentlich schon erstmal nicht so negativ dargestellt.
Das ist also die Umsetzung, die bemängelt wird.
Ja, da können wir das glaube ich zusammenfassen, oder?
Ja, durchaus. Allerdings weiß man auch nicht so genau, was die Idee ist, weil einerseits wird damit Werbung gemacht, dass man dort den Brief, wie wir den aus der Realwelt kennen, ins Netz bringt. Und andererseits wird damit Werbung gemacht, dass es einfach nur die Vorteile der E-Mail zusammengeführt mit Sicherheit und Datenschutz sei. Das ist aber sehr unterschiedlich. Insofern herrschen da offensichtlich auch viele Unklarheiten. Und die Tatsache, dass dort sich die Projekte immer wieder umbenennen und immer mal wieder neue Namen bekommen, spricht auch nicht gerade dafür, dass da jemand wirklich nachgedacht hat.
Okay, ich würde jetzt gerne noch mal zu einer ganz grundsätzlichen Sache kommen, die sich bei dieser De-Mail ja stellt, und zwar die technische Umsetzung von Verschlüsselung und Signatur. Also es soll ja so sein, dass einerseits sichergestellt wird, dass der Inhalt, der in dieser Mail steht, während des Sende- oder Versendungsvorgangs nicht verändert werden kann. Das heißt also der Empfänger soll sicher sein können, das was da drin steht, hat der Absender genauso geschrieben. Und dann soll es ja auch verschlüsselt sein. Also sagen, da darf zwischendurch, also jetzt mal irgendwie, wenn es zumindest nicht, wenn es um Behörden geht oder sowas, darf eigentlich keiner reingucken. Wie, also erstmal Signatur, wie wird das gemacht? Und wie zuverlässig ist das?
Im Gegensatz zu dem was man sonst so kennt, sowas wie GNU PG oder PGP, wird die Signatur nicht auf dem Rechner des, also die Signatur, die dort eingesetzt wird, nicht auf dem Rechner des Absenders berechnet. Sondern auf dem Server des Diensteanbieters.
Sollten wir vielleicht mal ganz allgemein sagen, was eine Signatur praktisch bedeutet, was man eigentlich tut.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade fragen.
Genau, das ist ja ein einfacher Konzept. Was man tut, ist, man berechnet einen mathematischen Wert, also eine Zahl über den Inhalt dieser E-Mail. Das heißt, man versucht mit dieser Zahl nachher abzugleichen, einmal beim Sender und beim Empfänger, ob sich der Inhalt verändert hat. Und man nimmt diese sogenannte Check-Summe, einen Hash-Wert, also eine bestimmte Zahl, und guckt, ob die sich nicht ändert. Das heißt, man hat einen mathematischen Verfahren, mit dem man die gesamte E-Mail betrachtet, daraus bildet man diesen Wert, und der darf sich halt nicht verändern. Denn die kleinste Veränderung am Inhalt der Mail würde diese Zahl verändern. Das ist eigentlich ein mathematisch günstiger Verfahren, das ist eine sogenannte Einwegfunktion. Das heißt, durchzuführen ist ja einfach. Bei den normalen Mails ist das im Prinzip nur noch ein Knopf oder eine kleine Berechnung jedenfalls, dauert nicht lange. Und aber derjenige, der die bekommt, kann damit auf leichtem Wege checken, hat sich da was verändert oder ist dieser Hash-Wert, also diese Check-Summe, gleichgeblieben. Das ist ungefähr, wenn man es jetzt mal ganz untechnisch ausdrücken will, so ungefähr der Weg.
Und das ist bei den Systemen, die derzeit eingesetzt werden, so, dass das auf meinem Rechner passiert, wenn ich die Mail schreibe?
Ja, ich benutze sowas seit etwa, ich weiß nicht, einer Dekade sogar. Ich glaube 15 Jahre gibt es das schon für E-Mails. Der Punkt ist nicht, das ist gar nicht der Punkt. Ich glaube der Punkt ist dran, dass es natürlich dafür sehr lange Verfahren gibt, die gut funktionieren, die open source sind, die doch nicht so kleiner Anteil benutzt. Also bei meinen Studenten etwa sind das gut 20% die solche Verfahren benutzen und die nicht nur signieren, sondern in der Inhalt verschlüsseln. Das ist ein kombiniertes Programm. In dem Fall GNU-PG und in der Bezahlvariante PGP. Die man sich downloaden kann für viele Clients. Sondern ist am Ende die Verstößung und Signierung für viele E-Mail Benutzer normal geworden. Also das heißt, das ist seit vielen Jahren bekannt. Das ist ein kostenloses Verfahren. Und für gerade so die technische Community schätze ich da die Frage, warum sollten wir das überhaupt benutzen? Wir haben sowas seit langem. Wir können E-Mails signieren und verstößen. Und zwar unter unserer Herrschaft. Wir haben die Schlüssel. Nicht irgendein Dritter signiert auf irgendeinem Rechner.
Aber was ist denn jetzt sozusagen der Nachteil dran? Dass das nicht direkt bei mir passiert, sondern auf dem Anbieter. Der wird sozusagen die Verbindung von mir zu Hause zu seinem Webportal bestimmt verschlüsseln und macht das dann irgendwie, wirft da Mathe-Voodoo drauf, damit das irgendwie bei der Übertragung funktioniert. Was ist denn der Nachteil für mich als User?
Also, dass die Verbindung zwischen dir und dem Anbieter oder seinem Web-Server verschlüsselt ist, sorgt nur dafür, dass Leute, die außerhalb sitzen, diese Nachrichten nicht lesen können. Aber dein Anbieter kann das schonen. Und er kann die Nachricht eigentlich auch ändern, bevor er sie weiterleitet. Also es gibt keine Garantie. Das ist eigentlich eine simulierte Sicherheit, was dahinter steht.
Wir wollen mal vielleicht mit dem normalen Papierbrief vergleichen. Das ist also im Prinzip als wenn der Anbieter den Umschlag öffnet, einen neuen Umschlag darum macht und den Brief weiter sendet. Also es gibt einen kurzen Moment, also in Digitalien ist es natürlich ein ganz kurzer Moment, wo sie eben den Brief kurz öffnen. So kann man das vergleichen. Das würden wir im Bereich der Papierpost als inakzeptabel finden.
Das ist ja dann, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, beim Empfänger dann genauso. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass der Empfänger den Brief auspackt, sondern der Anbieter, bei dem der Empfänger ist, der packt den Brief aus und sagt dann hier guck mal Empfänger, so sieht der Brief aus.
Der packt den auf dem Server aus und das was er dem Empfänger dann anzeigt ist der Brief selbst und dass die Signatur in Ordnung ist.
Das heißt also ich hab pro Sendevorgang zwei eigentlich nicht beteiligte Parteien, also vielleicht wenn es der selber anbietet ist nur einer, aber im Prinzip zwei nicht beteiligte Parteien, die einen Blick in die Kommunikation haben. Hat das juristische irgendwelche Konsequenzen oder ist es im Konzept derzeit nicht vorgesehen, dass das Konsequenzen hat? Also da könnte man ja sagen, wenn da Dritte dran sein können und das bei jedem Vorgang auch sind, dann ist es halt doch nicht so ganz sicher.
Na da wird natürlich wieder mal die legalistische Schiene gefahren, zu sagen, also der Anbieter ist natürlich von vorne rein im ganzen Konzept vertrauensvoll, denn er ist ja zertifiziert, er hält sich also an die Regeln und insofern wäre von der juristischen Seite natürlich kein Problem. Der Anbieter ist ja Teil dieses Konzepts. Er ist der Bürgerportaldienstanbieter, muss sich zertifizieren und ist damit einer von den guten TM.
Wie, diese Zertifizierung, ist die ungefähr so vertrauenswürdig wie das TÜV-Siegel für die VZ-Netzwerke oder?
Ah, das würden wir nie so, nein.
Nein, also hier muss man schon sagen, zumindest, das ist rechtlich so vorgesehen und ist auch faktisch so, hier hat die Oberhoheit die BSI, der Bundesamt für Sicherheit, in der Informationstechnik. Das heißt, es ist schon ein technischer Dienstleister der Bundesregierung hier am Start, der eine Zertifizierung macht, wie man sie aus anderen Bereichen, aus IT-Secure, die Bereichen kennt.
Aber die prüfen nur, die prüfen nur, die machen die Zertifizierung nicht selbst. Also die prüfen nur, ob die Zertifizierung ordentlich gelaufen ist.
Und die Zertifizierung wird dann von Dritten?
Genau, das sind Privatunternehmen, die sich selbst auch zertifizieren lassen, dass sie vertrauenswürdige Zertifizierer sind.
Genau, also man vergibt diese Aufträge. Das ist auch tatsächlich gesetzlich so geregelt. Es gibt einen Paragraph 2 und 21 im Bürgerportalgesetz, wo genau, in diesem Amt.
Die E-Mail-Gesetz, wie gesagt, die werden alle immer umbenannt. Das heißt inzwischen auch die E-Mail-Gesetz.
Ich sag immer noch Bürgerportalgesetz. Man hat ja eh Schwierigkeiten, die Sachen auszusetzen.
Im Bezahl-Mail-Gesetz?
Ja, im Bezahl-Mail-Gesetz. Sehr schön. Also das heißt, da ist von der juristischen Perspektive kein Problem. Technisch sehen wir das natürlich anders. Also klar ist das eine Gefahr.
Ich wollte noch mal kurz beim Zertifikat bleiben. Ich hab ja dieses VZ-Ding angesprochen, aus vollem Grund. Da hat der TÜV ja dann später gesagt, naja, wir haben ja diese Software zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt geprüft und als Siegel vergeben. Und da sind ja möglicherweise Änderungen passiert. Wie ist denn das bei den Anbietern? Also beim BSI wird das Zertifikat vergeben oder durch das BSI von Dritten geprüft. Gucken die die ganze Zeit auf diese Systeme? Oder ist es so, die kriegen halt irgendwann Zertifikat und dann liegt die ganze Technik schon auf dem Server des Anbieters und wir müssen quasi darauf vertrauen, dass er so wie das Zertifikat bekommen hat, dass das alles so am Start bleibt.
Also nein, wenn man so die technischen Richtlinien sich anschaut, dann muss der rezertifiziert werden, wenn er Änderungen vornimmt.
Das System ist abgenommen, so wie es angegeben wird. Wenn man dort etwas ändert, dann muss man sich erneut zertifizieren.
Also zumindest dieser Teil jeweils.
So ist es doch festgelegt.
Würdet ihr das jetzt so sagen, also ich muss das ist der Punkt, wo ich euch nochmal fragen muss, wie seht ihr das? Ist das ausreichend oder kann dann trotzdem sozusagen der Anbieteränderung vornehmen?
Jetzt kann man immer sehen, unter welchen Gesichtspunkten man sowas betrachtet. Das eine ist natürlich, dass Zertifizierung in vielen Bereichen ein üblicher Weg ist. Natürlich kann man jetzt wieder sagen, jetzt sind Unternehmen teilweise, wir haben schon über die Telekom gesprochen, die sind bereits mit Datenskandalen und zwar internen Datenskandalen, also wo sie Daten, die sie selbst sammeln, das war ja im Telefonbereich, eben missbraucht haben. Da kann man sich natürlich jetzt wieder fragen, ok, jetzt wenn man annimmt diese Anbieter, dem wird generell vertraut. Ist das eigentlich eine Annahme, die unter diesen Gesichtspunkten valide ist? Aber die juristische Herangehensweise ist natürlich anders. Man betrachtet diesen technischen Komplex als gegeben, wenn die Zertifizierung positiv durchlaufen ist. Also als Hacker sind natürlich immer ein bisschen anders und ich will auch nicht so schnell vergessen, was die Öffentlichkeit offenbar sehr schnell vergisst, nämlich in welcher frechen Weise die ihre Daten da missbraucht haben und da Leute bespitzelt haben und ich sehe nicht unbedingt, dass es nicht bei Anbietern auch weiterhin vorkommen kann. Die Daten sind ja auch finanziell wertvoll. Wirtschaftsspionage ist ja durchaus florierender Graumarkt.
Also aus meiner Sicht noch ein Argument dagegen, dass nämlich die Sicherheit der Signatur und auch der Verschließung sozusagen eigentlich nicht wirklich gegeben ist, weil ich da auf den Anbieter vertrauen muss, was ich bei den normalen Systemen nicht muss.
Das wissen die auch.
Sie müssen das nochmal betonen.
Das wissen die auch. Also das ist nicht so, dass die nicht zugeben, dass jemand, der wirklich Sicherheit haben will, garantierte Sicherheit, der muss sich selbst nochmal extra um Verschließungen kümmern.
Ja, das ist zum Beispiel bei diesem sogenannten Dokumentenspeicher explizit vorgesehen, dass man dort eben nicht unbedingt auf die Verschlüsselung vertrauen muss, die der Anbieter hat, sondern dass man eigene, verschlüsselte Daten in diesem Dokumentenserver ablegen kann.
Okay, also nochmal. Im De-Mail-Gesetz gibt es eine optional Komponente, die heißt Dokumentensafe. De-Safe. Und in diesem De-Safe, der ist dazu da, um meine Dokumente sicher aufzubewahren, aber ich muss mich selber um Verschlüsselung kümmern. Hab ich das richtig zusammengefasst?
Man kann dort auch verschlüsselte Dokumente ablegen, die man selbst verschlüsselt hat. Da geht es denen darum, dass natürlich für diese Nachschlüsse, die wir schon angesprochen haben, wenn man also etwa seinen eigenen Schlüssel nicht mehr...
Das meinte ich gerade. Sie stellen einen sicheren Dokumenten sich zur Verfügung, sagen aber, wenn ihr wirklich eure Dokumente sicher abschmeichern wollt, dann müsst ihr sie selber verschlüsseln.
Ja, so sagen sie es natürlich nicht, aber in gewisser Weise.
Aber das ist die Konsequenz.
In gewisser Weise schon.
Diese Nachschlüsselproblematik ist natürlich für viele Leute ein großes Problem und überhaupt die Tatsache, dass eben die Verschlüsselung nicht von Ende zu Ende ist. Denn jemand mit Verstand wird immer versuchen wollen, die Verschlüsselung im eigenen Hoheitsbereich in der Kontrolle zu haben und von Ende zu Ende zu verschlüsseln, und zwar ohne Unterbrechung, ohne ein Sicherheitsrisiko in der Mitte, und das heißt De-Mail. Das ist tatsächlich ein Sicherheitsrisiko. Ich würde das persönlich inakzeptabel finden.
Also es ist der eine Punkt sozusagen, dass die Anbieter selber, dass man dem vertrauen muss, aber wir gehen jetzt mal von dem Fall, den ihr natürlich nie befürworten würdet, aber wir gehen jetzt mal von aus, der Anbieter sei vertrauenswürdig. Jetzt ist es ja bei dieser sogenannten Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung, was er genannt hat, also GPG und PGP, so dass die Software, die dem zugrunde liegt, ist open source. Das heißt, jeder kann sich den Quellcode angucken. Das heißt auch, die Verschlüsselung basiert nicht darauf, dass ich sozusagen geheim halte, wie sie funktioniert, also so im Sinne von, haha, ihr wisst nicht, wie es geht, deswegen könnt ihr es auch nicht entlüsseln, sondern das funktioniert mathematisch. Wie ist es bei diesem System? Ist in diesem Gesetzeskonzept vorgesehen, dass die Software, die die Anbieter verwenden, auch so in einem Prüfprozess durch die Community ausgesetzt ist? Oder dürfen die sozusagen da im geheimen Kämmerlein werken, was sie da machen?
Also nein, der Community wird da überhaupt nichts übergeholfen, was Prüfprozesse oder so angeht.
Nein, das ist auch nicht open source.
Es muss auch nicht open source sein. Andererseits, sie fordern, dass die Sicherheit nach dem Stand der Technik garantiert wird. Und die Verschlüsselungsverfahren, die eingesetzt werden, dem Stand der Technik entsprechen.
Das ist aber natürlich nur juristische Definition. Der Stand der Technik ist nur von Juristen definiert und nicht unbedingt, wie wir Stand der Technik jetzt als Techies verstehen würden.
Also man könnte sagen, hingehen und sagen, so Stand der Technik ist open source Verschlüsselung?
Also Stand der Technik ist eigentlich open source Verschlüsselung. Stand der Technik ist auch, dass die Verfahren alle offen liegen. Damit am Ende tatsächlich das Einzige, was geheim bleiben soll, ist der Schlüssel.
Das heißt aber, das müsste man im Zweifel einklagen?
Um das mal nicht zu formulieren, ich glaube, da ist niemand in Klage befugt. Also ich glaube, das kannst du einfach nicht vor Gericht durchsetzen.
Also das heißt sozusagen, wir müssen nicht nur vertrauen, dass der Anbieter nichts Böses will, wir müssen auch darauf vertrauen, dass der Anbieter technisch kompetent ist, weil wir können die Verschlüsselungsprogrammierung nicht selber nachprüfen. Sind die Anbieter, die derzeit Telekom, Post, GMX, United Internet, sind die denn als vertrauenswürdig einzustufen?
Also ich würde nicht mal sagen, dass das BSI vertrauenswürdig ist. Das Problem ist, die haben selbst...
Jetzt kommt Jörg mit den dicken Dingen.
Na ja, die haben selbst ein Verschlüsselungsangebot, das heißt Chiasmus oder Chiasmus. Und das basiert darauf, dass das ganze Verfahren geheim ist. Also das Verfahren ist nicht offengelegt.
Man nennt es Security by Obscurity.
Genau.
Das heißt, man vertraut darauf, dass durch Nichtkenntnis eine höhere Sicherheit gewährleistet ist. Das ist natürlich aus technischer Sicht fragwürdig und ist auch sehr oft gescheitert.
Und das ist seit 120 Jahren out das Verfahren.
Okay, also auf meiner Liste steht jetzt ein Punkt 4. Technische Kompetenz der Anbieter ist fragwürdig. Und wir kommen jetzt nochmal zurück. Mit den Anrufern haben wir so kleine Zeitsprünge. Es geht jetzt nochmal um einen Spam. Und da hat Edwin angerufen. Hallo. Möchtest du bei den E-Mails spammen? Oder warum rufst du an?
Nein, nein, nein. Wir hatten vorhin ganz kurz die Argumentation, dass ein User sich gesorgt hat, dass Spam über generische Verfahren möglich wäre. Nochmal sozusagen ein Themenwechsel. Ich denke nicht, dass das möglich sein wird. Und zwar aus dem folgenden Grund, da spammen wir ja eigentlich den Vorteil der normalen E-Mail-Ausnutzung, die kostenlos sind.
Du meinst, die Kostenpflichtigkeit wird die sicher abstoßen?
Ja, das ist jetzt der eine Punkt. Dann könnte man sagen, okay, eventuell hacken sie irgendeinen Account und verschicken es über den einen. Es ist aber so, dass ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch nicht einen kostenlosen E-Mail-Anbieter habe, sondern einen kommerziellen. Und der verbietet mir sozusagen, mehr als 200 E-Mails in der Stunde zu verschicken. Also da denke ich, gäbe es schon einige sinnvolle Beschränkungen auf Provider oder Serviceanbieterseite, um sowas zu verändern.
Also das heißt, du würdest sagen, die Werbung damit, dass Spam damit sicher bekämpft wird, könnte schon ein paar valide Punkte haben?
Denke ich auf jeden Fall. Und prinzipiell sehe ich schon ein paar Punkte, die sinnvoll sind bei der De-Mail.
Ja, nämlich?
Zum Beispiel wäre auch der Umweltschutz ein Thema, wo man sagen könnte, langfristig gesehen, klar, jetzt am Anfang, wo es so eine Umstiegsphase ist, wo praktisch viel noch per Brief gemacht wird oder Post halt klassisch. Und manche Leute das sozusagen noch nicht haben, dann müsste das da ausgedruckt werden. Dann ist es auch die Frage, ob das umweltschützend ist. Aber prinzipiell haben wir ja heute fast jeder Computer. Da ist es schon sinnvoll, dass man irgendwann mal auf die digitale Welt umspringt. Ob das System so wie es gemacht wird, sinnvoller ist, das ist die Frage.
Wir hatten ja diese ökologische Komponente schon zweimal so ein bisschen gestreift. Leider ist es natürlich so, dass sich in diesem sechsmonatigen Test in einer T-City in Friedrichshafen hat sich jetzt natürlich nicht bewahrheitet. Das liegt natürlich daran, dass genau wie du sagst, dieser Ernstprozess noch nicht so durchgestylt war, dass man also zwischendurch doch wieder drucken musste und dass sie sogar so ein paar Blüten da eingebaut haben, wie wenn man sich jetzt auf den Portal eingeloggt hat als Testnutzer bei De-Mail und versucht hat, seine De-Mail zu bekommen. Man hat dreimal ein paar Passworte eingegeben und hat man per Post ein neues zugeschickt bekommen. Also da waren einfach noch viele Sachen, die sich erst wohl einrütteln müssen, sofern die Leute eben mitmachen. Dann kann natürlich schon durchaus sein, dass das ein Rohrkrepierer wird. Das wollen wir mal sehen, ob sich die Investitionen da wirklich lohnen. Aber ich sehe deinen Punkt. Klar, alle wünschen sich seit, weiß ich nicht, wie lange, 15, 20 Jahre, Papierlose Büro. Leider ist ja das Gegenteil eingetreten. Also wir müssen mal über das Volumen reden. Wir reden über etwa 20 Milliarden Briefe innerhalb von Deutschland. Das ist also, was die Post so angibt. Und davon sind derzeit, zumindest nach den groben Schätzungen der Post, etwa die Hälfte Briefe mit juristischem Belang. Da natürlich diese ganze private Korrespondenz einen stark abgenommen. Wer schreibt schon noch einen Brief, wo er eine E-Mail schicken kann? Und deshalb ist natürlich der Anteil an Briefen, die irgendwie geschäftlich, behördlich, aber jedenfalls eine Rechtsfolge haben, schon mit 50 Prozent sehr hoch. Irgendwie habe ich dieses Ökodokument, Argumente finde ich schon valide. Ich würde mir auch wünschen, dass da viel automatisiert werden könnte. Man muss natürlich auch mal an Leute denken, wie sie in den Friedrichshafen an Anwendungstests durchgespielt wurden. Wir nehmen mal Aufenthaltsgenehmigungen, die zum Beispiel elektronisch erteilt werden. Man muss dann halt nicht mehr zum Arbeitsamt und zur Ausländerbehörde, sondern kann klicken. Das ist natürlich schon praktisch. Oder bei einer Geburt, jeder, der ein Kind gekriegt hat, weiß, dass es unglaublich viele Behördengänge gibt. Und zwar innerhalb von kurzer Zeit. Da freut man sich schon, wenn man diese Urkunde zur Geburt eben kriegen kann digital. Ich sehe die Argumente, aber guckt man sich das dann genauer an?
Einen kleinen Punkt hätte ich auch noch, wenn ich durfte. Wie sieht es denn aus mit normalen E-Mails im bisherigen Geschäftsbereich? Also wir haben auch ein fast papierloses Büro, haben aber jetzt nicht, so wie ein User am Anfang der Sendung erklärt hat, dass dann hinterher eine Mail zurückgeschickt wird, okay, wir haben die E-Mail empfangen, aber machen eigentlich schon eigentlich sehr viel per normaler E-Mail. Ist das dann eigentlich ein rechtsgültiges Geschäft oder kann man das dann hinterher sagen, wir haben eigentlich gar keinen Vertrag?
Nein, die meisten Rechtsgeschäfte kann man formfrei schließen, die kann man per Handschlag schließen, die kann man mündlich schließen, oder kann man eben auch per E-Mail schließen.
Also dann geht es eigentlich nur darum, dass es wirklich die behördlichen Dinge sind, oder?
Ja, du kannst natürlich auch mal denken, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel in ein anderes Unternehmen zukaufst, also wenn es ein Rechtsgeschäft ist, das unglaublich viele andere Vertragsfolgen hat und so weiter, dann ist es natürlich etwas anderes, als wenn du mit einem Kunden jetzt einen Vertrag abschließt.
Wobei das auch Grenzen hat, also nicht alles, auch die De-Mail übernimmt nicht alles in rechtlicher Hinsicht. Also es entspricht zum Beispiel nicht der Schriftform. Also wenn irgendein Gesetz Schriftformen vorschreibt, dann reicht die De-Mail auch nicht aus.
Was?
Das sagt ihr jetzt?
Das ist ja aber auch mal interessant.
Nach anderthalb Stunden erfahren wir, dass die De-Mail, die den Brief ersetzen soll, nicht die Schriftform ersetzt.
Männer immer mit der Ruhe. Nein, der Punkt ist doch, es ist schon klar, dass sich viele andere Rechtsnormen, die wir in verschiedenen Gesetzen haben, die irgendwelche Papierformen vorschreiben, die müssen sich natürlich nach und nach anpassen. Das ist aber auch der Plan.
Es gibt schon...
Also man kann schon elektronische Formen wählen. Also das heißt, mit Hilfe von irgendwie mit einer qualifizierten elektronischen Signatur nach einem Signaturgesetz kann man sozusagen wie bei der Schriftform genau die gleichen Verträge unterschreiben oder was auch immer.
Okay, das würde bei mir jetzt sofort die Frage nach sich ziehen. Es gibt also ein Gesetz über eine qualifizierte elektronische Signatur. Genau. Warum ist das bei der De-Mail keine qualifizierte elektronische Signatur?
Das liegt daran, dass es nicht mal eine fortgeschrittene elektronische Signatur ist.
Was aber immer das bedeutet?
Also es gibt so ein Drei-Stufen-System. Eine einfache elektronische Signatur, eine fortgeschrittene elektronische Signatur und eine qualifizierte elektronische Signatur. Und die qualifizierte elektronische Signatur kann die eigenhändige Namensunterschrift ersetzen.
Warum ist das bei De-Mail nicht so?
Das liegt daran, dass schon die fortgeschrittene elektronische Signatur voraussetzt, dass du den Computer, auf dem die Signatur erstellt wird, unter deiner Kontrolle hast. Und wie wir das vorhin gesagt haben, bei De-Mail wird die Signatur auf dem Server vollzogen.
Ich gebe auf. Das ist die Stelle, an der ich jetzt aufgebe. Wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, um weiter drüber zu reden. Nee, ich gebe nicht auf im Sinne von, ich verstehe nichts mehr, sondern ich gebe auf im Sinne von, ich gebe die Hoffnung auf, dass dieses System irgendwann noch mal zu irgendeiner Spruchreife kommt, die mir vertrauenswürdig erscheint. Nee, damit warten wir jetzt bis nach dem Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Heute, letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaosradio noch eine halbe Stunde mit mir, Markus Richter und mit Konstanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club und mit Jörg Pohle von der Humboldt-Uni Berlin. Es geht um die De-Mail. De-Mail, die also mir sozusagen, ich habe diesmal so begegnet, dass man gesagt hat, okay, früher gab es Briefe von den Behörden, jetzt soll es De-Mail geben. Also Behörden schreiben euch und das ist dann alles sozusagen, das hat auch so Behördentouch, soll also irgendwie sicher sein. Wir haben jetzt gerade eine halbe Stunde rausgefunden, das ersetzt nicht die Schriftform, dazu müsste es dann nochmal extra Zeug geben. Außerdem gibt es schon vier Punkte, die auf meiner Liste stehen, die mich dazu bringen wollen, dass ich eigentlich die E-Mail wahrscheinlich nicht verwenden werde. Das eine ist sozusagen, wenn euch eine De-Mail geschickt wird und euer Anbieter sagt, ich hab die bekommen, dann gilt die als gelesen. Das heißt, dann fangen die juristischen Schriften, Fristen anzulaufen. Dann liegen diese Mails ja bei den Anbietern. Und da können jede Menge Behörden und andere Institutionen ziemlich einfach darauf zugreifen. Es werden Zertifikate vergeben, die die technische Zuverlässigkeit der Anbieter sozusagen zertifizieren. Also das ist alles OK-Stempel, aber die Art und Weise, wie die vergeben werden, ist ein bisschen fragwürdig. Und dasselbe gilt auch für die technische Kompetenz der Anbieter. Wir haben jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Müssen wir noch weiter reden?
Ja, wir haben noch total tolle Argumente, die wir auch noch bringen müssen. Also, es gibt ein paar Sachen, die, wenn man sich das angesehen hat, bei der Deutschen Post, die ja den E-Postbrief hat, die sie jetzt bewirbt und der Martell werden soll, der De-Mail oder das ganze De-Mail-Projekt ist, dann fällt einem bei der Registrierung gleich was auf. Die haben doch tatsächlich, die haben sich nicht entblödet, gleichzeitig zu der Registrierung, zu ihrem E-Postbrief ein Gewinnspiel anzubieten. Und da fiel mir jetzt ein bisschen wie schuppenvoll in den Augen, was die meisten Leute glaube ich nicht wissen. Und was in Deutschland wenig bekannt ist, ist, dass die Deutsche Post einer der größten Adresshändler in Deutschland sind, die also in kleinen und in großen Tranchen für kommerzielle und private Anbieter Adressen vertickt. Und die nicht nur Adressenlisten vertickt, sondern die auch Korrekturen für Adresslisten, die man schon hat, macht. Also zum Beispiel wenn da Vornamen oder Taipos drin sind, so was korrigiert die. Es ist ein sehr großer Adresshändler. Und es ist glaube ich vielen nicht bewusst, die sich da registrieren. Aber dieses Gewinnspiel fand ich so sehr lustig, weil man kann den Haken setzen oder nicht innerhalb der Bedingungen, die sich die Post da selber gegeben hat und die man natürlich unterzeichnen muss.
Fürs Gewinnspiel oder für die De-Mail?
Für die De-Mail wird die Weitergabe dieser Adressen nämlich nicht ausgeschlossen. Das heißt, ob man bei dem Gewinnspiel mitmacht oder nicht. Man kann trotzdem auf tolle neue Preise ausschreiben, warten. Und entsprechend ist uns als Chaos Computer Club in den letzten Tagen von Betriebsräten der Deutschen Post zugegangen, also E-Mail zugegangen, die sich so desinformiert fühlen von ihrem eigenen Arbeitgeber, dass sie gerne mal das technische Konzept eigentlich erklärt bekommen haben wollen vom Chaos Computer Club.
Mitarbeiter der Firma, die den E-Postbrief... Betriebsräte sind ja auch Mitarbeiter, oder nicht?
Ja schon, aber die haben ja meist noch einen anderen Blick auf uns.
Naja, aber trotzdem. Es sind sozusagen Mitarbeiter der Firma, die das Produkt anbieten.
Genau, die haben nämlich folgendes gemacht in ihrer Betriebsratssitzung. Die haben sich die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen mal gemeinschaftlich durchgelesen. Dabei haben sie entdeckt, da steht was ganz anderes als in der hochpolierten Werbung. Und das ist ihnen natürlich dabei aufgefallen, denn wir können nur jedem empfehlen, sich diese AGB mal durchzulesen. Es lohnt sich hier, denn es sind doch einige Zumutungen.
Katze, hast du mal so Tipps jetzt, damit wir nicht alle jetzt irgendwie...
Es geht vor allen Dingen um Adresshandel. Und da muss man sich schon fragen, was hat sich da die Post dabei gedacht? Wir wissen, dass das bei der Post ein Geschäftsmodell seit Jahren ist, um Adressen zu vererticken. Und die meisten Leute sind gegenüber der Post sehr ehrlich. Sie sagen ihnen sogar sehr schnell, wann sie umziehen, weil sie natürlich ihre Post bekommen wollen. Die haben immer den aktuellsten Datenbestand.
Dürfen die denn das?
Natürlich dürfen die das. Wenn man registriert, dann wird man dem zustimmen.
Wir haben jetzt noch Mandy. Du wolltest uns was zur Sicherheit in Behörden erzählen.
Wir wissen ja, Elena ist sehr fortgeschritten. Ich hab einfach nur mein Kind in der Kita angemettet. Auf einmal wussten die, was ich im ganzen Haus schon mal beantragt habe. Wie weit ist es denn kompatibel? Weil ich sag mal, wenn es so ein Portal ist, wo man viele Behördensachen machen kann, sind die gleichzusetzen mit Elena? Er setzt das vielleicht irgendwo an Elena? Weil es ist ja dann umfangs praktisch mit einem System theoretisch zu arbeiten. Und wie weit kriege ich denn eigentlich vielleicht so eine Bemerkung, dass sich irgendjemand meine Akte doch mal aufgerufen hat? Oder mit Kollegen mit anderen Abteilungen zusammenarbeiten? Weil ich habe die Sache auch nur durch Zufall eigentlich so rausbekommen. Wo ich sagte, okay, man muss halt auch wahnsinnig aufpassen.
Also natürlich, wir haben mit der Ernst zum Anfang erwähnt, dieses Projekt, die E-Mail und die Gesetzgebung und die Rechtsverordnungen und dann alle dazugehört, ist natürlich schon Teil der High-Tech-Strategie der Bundesregierung, wozu natürlich viele andere Projekte gehören, die eben möglichst dafür sorgen sollen, dass diese Gesellschaft mal irgendwann im digitalen Zeitalter ankommt. Aber zumindest aus meiner Kenntnis gibt es bisher überhaupt keinen Zusammenhang zu diesem Entgeltnachweis. Elena und wir konnten da auch bisher keine Hinweise finden. Natürlich gibt es Szenarien, die immer wieder in den Konzepten auftauchten, zum Beispiel, dass man die Bürger, die ja nicht so richtig Lust hatten, in den vergangenen Jahren bei solchen Systemen mitzumachen, die Freiwilligkeit mal vielleicht ein bisschen nach vorne bringt, indem man etwa sagt, naja, die Finanzbehörden schicken ihre Steuerbescheide über De-Mail raus. Oder so was in der Zukunft natürlich. Damit hätte man natürlich eine sehr starke Inzentivierung. Das heißt, Leute würden, weil Steuerbescheide eben ganz viele Leute betreffen, da mitmachen oder eben vielleicht Bescheide vom Arbeitsamt, vom Ausländeramt. Also solche Fragen. Aber bisher sehen wir keine konkreten Hinweise, dass es Verbindungen zu Elendr gibt.
Also zu Elendr direkt nicht. Aber Elster hat genau das gleiche. Die gleiche Funktionsweise. Eigentlich dient es der Kommunikation zwischen dem Bürger oder dem Unternehmen und der Steuerbehörde.
Also Elster ist die elektronische, die Abgabe.
Eigentlich praktisch so wie Intranet oder so.
Elektronische Steuererklärung.
Genau, das ist dieses Elster-System, wo man ja unter manchen Umständen, also manche sind ja bereits gezwungen, das elektronisch einzureichen.
Selbstständige zum Beispiel.
Ja, das war ja auch komisch. Dann haben wir Anfangs von ganz anderen Abteilungen bekommen, die uns damit jetzt nicht so richtig zu tun haben. Und dann denkt man auch, okay, die nächsten wissen eigentlich Bescheid, denen haben die eigentlich ja Einfluss drauf. Und wenn ich eigentlich nur eine Sache beantragen will, wissen vielleicht fünf Abteilungen. Und wenn man auch vielleicht nur ganz einfache Anträge stellt, einfach um mal Dinge nachzufragen, und dann auf einmal an ganz anderen Abteilungen landen und man sagt, man will eigentlich ja nur nachfragen, was ich beim Jugendamt mit irgendwelchen Umgangsformen, man hat eigentlich nur eine Anfrage, keine konkrete Ausführung.
Du hast so eher diese Angst, dass es stärker integriert wird und verschiedene Behörden auf dieselben Datenbestände zugreifen. Ist das etwas, was ich da rausgesungen habe?
Man muss das einfach nur ein Stück weiter denken. Und jetzt noch ein anderer Punkt ist, was nennt man ja doch gerade bei älteren Leuten oder bei Behinderten oder was ich, die bestimmte Sachen vielleicht auch nicht so alleine machen können. Und ja, beim Papierkram, okay, dann braucht man vielleicht auch noch jemand. Aber so im Internet, das heißt, man muss auch erstmal...
Ich kann dir jetzt in der Tat nicht mehr ganz folgen. Im Prinzip sagst du, das System ist dir auch nichts, weil sozusagen das...
Nee, das ist jetzt ein zweiter Punkt. Wenn jetzt irgendwann wirklich nur der Computer, das heißt, wir müssen ja den Leuten auch wirklich auch einen Anschluss haben.
Das ist ja momentan noch freiwillig, also so weit sind wir noch nicht. Das wäre in der Tat auch mal ein zweiter Punkt, den man aber glaube ich erst in so keine Ahnung, zwei bis fünf Jahren diskutieren könnte, ob und wie viel man schon gezwungen ist und ob es ohne Computer überhaupt noch geht. Aber das ist glaube ich heute nicht ganz so das Thema, sondern das ist De-Mail. Das ist ja im Moment auch eine freiwillige Sache, die aber schon dazu dienen soll, dass man quasi von Behörden Schreiben in Empfang nehmen kann, wenn man will. Und zum Empfangen dieser Schreiben hat Murdoch noch eine Frage.
Und zwar wollte ich eigentlich sagen, dass ich das eigentlich auch ein bisschen unverständlich finde, dass wenn eine E-Mail ankommt und ich ruf sie nicht ab, dass sie zugestellt gilt. Und zwar wollte ich eigentlich nur dazu bemerken, am 7. Juli 2009 hat das Landgericht Hamburg in einen Fall, wo jemand eine Abmahnung per E-Mail geschickt hat, die hat er nicht gekriegt, weil die Firewall, die geblockt hat, beschlossen, dass die E-Mail trotzdem als angekommen und somit als verfüggerecht und so weiter.
Ja, aber das war seine eigene Firewall. Also das muss man halt auch sagen. Solche Entscheidungen sind dann immer sehr auf den Einzelfall fixiert. Und es war wohl seine eigene Firewall, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ja, Landgericht Hamburg, müssen wir da mehr sagen.
Die Internet-Spezialisten.
Aber da sieht man halt sowas, die gehen ähnliche Wege. Und das ist natürlich ein Ding, ehrlich gesagt, was ich auch nicht schön finde. Ich glaube, ich beim postalischen Weg, ähnliche Gesetze, wenn das Ding in Briefkasten landet, ist eigentlich erst mal zugestellt, angewiesen. Somit hat er das erhalten und muss eigentlich darauf reagieren. Auch wenn das noch nicht geöffnet hat.
Ja, aber eben nicht bei der Poststelle. Das heißt, wenn du den Schriebs bekommst in deinen Briefkasten, dass zum Beispiel ein Einschreiben da ist, dann gilt es erst dann als Empfangen, wenn du dahin gehst und es abholst.
Das Einschreiben, nicht nur den Zettel.
Genau.
Und das ist nämlich genau der Unterschied, den wir versucht haben, von dieser Briefwelt in die digitale Welt zu erklären. Also sie haben es vorverlegt. Und zwar außerhalb deines Machtbereiches, in der Briefkasse, ist dein Machtbereich aber nicht etwa, was da bei dem Server, bei dem Anbieter liegt. Das ist, was wir gerade sagen wollten. Also ich lese eine Wisse Grundeskepsis auch bei dir heraus, richtig?
Definitiv. Also ich hab auch die ganzen News bei den ganzen Alt-V-News gelesen, über die E-Post und hatte auch kurz nachdem auch schon Werbung davon im Briefkasten. Und hatte aber schon einiges gelesen und werde mich definitiv dann natürlich anmelden. Ein Freund von mir hat das gleich getan am ersten Tag.
Und hat er eine Nummer gekriegt oder hat er noch seinen eigenen Vornamen?
Ich hab ihn gar nicht gefragt. Aber er ist so Early Adapter, also davon ab, er wollte einfach so gleiten, als er es ist daran. Und das war so der Punkt.
Jetzt haben wir immerhin schon sagen, von zwei Leuten gehört, die zumindest da mitgemacht haben. Jetzt nehmen wir noch Benni dazu. Der hat eine Frage zum Löschen von Dokumenten. Benni, was genau meinst du?
Ja, guten Abend. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt E-Mails oder Dokumente löschen möchte, ist das überhaupt möglich? Oder werden die dann auch vom Anbieter vernichtet? Oder sind die dann immer noch irgendwo auf dem Surfer und zugreifbar für Strafverfolgungsbehörden oder Ähnliches?
Also die sollen dann schon gelöscht werden. Die Deutsche Post, die ja diesen E-Postbrief anbietet, die schreibt allerdings in ihrer AGB, dass das durchaus eine ganze Weile dauern kann und dass sie keine Gewähr dafür übernimmt, dass das sofort gelöscht wird. Oder auch nur in näherer Zukunft.
Ja, das ist auch ein Kritikpunkt, der jetzt häufiger einfach genannt wird. Da man natürlich in der eigenen Sphäre sagen kann, also löschig, und zwar gelöscht wirklich sicher, kann man natürlich nicht unbedingt bei dem Anbieter, muss man sich aber jeweils an die AGB durchlesen. Wir haben ja quasi für diesen speziellen Fall nur diese einen AGB, die schon vorliegen.
Das ist dann aber auch nicht im Zertifizierungsprozess vorgesehen, dass da irgendwie übers Löschen mitzertifiziert wird.
Die werden gerade in die Köpfe gewiegt, man weiß nicht so genau, oder?
Also das Löschen wird zumindest in den technischen Richtlinien angesprochen. Auch, dass es halt geschehen muss.
Und dass es auch einen technischen Vorgang geben muss, der auch beschrieben sein muss. Das ist auf jeden Fall in den Richtlinien mit drin.
Also es wird anders als mit sozialen Netzwerken, wo man den Account gar nicht löschen kann.
Na, da wird als gelöscht markiert.
Okay, also wir wissen es doch nicht genau, aber es soll auf jeden Fall irgendwie stattfinden. Ich hoffe, das hat jetzt weitergeholfen.
Ich wollte eigentlich Benni mir was fragen.
Wir haben nicht mehr so richtig viel Zeit. Und dann hat Paul angerufen, was ich spannend finde, weil er ja am Anfang der Sendung auch angerufen hat.
Hast du dir mal überlegt, wer das bezahlt?
Die Löscherei, oder wie?
Nein, die ganze Projekt, die De-Mail, wer bezahlt das eigentlich?
Der Steuerzahler.
Ja, und der Gebührenzahler, genau. Und wer hat was davon?
Die Behörden.
Also, na, und die Unternehmen, denn die sollen da sparen. Ich finde diese, wem nützt das eigentlich, Frage immer ganz spannend.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also bei der Post sozusagen, die nimmt dasselbe Geld pro Mail an wie für einen Brief, hat aber viel weniger Aufriss damit.
Nicht wahr? Aber wir bezahlen zwar Gebühren und Steuern. Naja, ich meine ja nur. Wollen wir jetzt mal Paul versuchen?
Genau, jetzt fragen wir noch Paul. Paul hat ja am Anfang der Sendung angerufen. Hallo Paul.
Ja, hallo nochmal.
Und am Anfang war deine Meinung zu die E-Mail was gewesen?
Ja, ich hab gesagt, dass ich es privat nicht nutzen werde, weil ich so meine E-Mails auch sonst, also jetzt nicht Sorgen habe, dass sie mitgelesen werden, etc. dass ich bei Behörden, dass ich da das nicht brauche, dass da ja die Moment auch noch also schön per Brief kommen. Und ich glaube, das war so meine Meinung, oder? Ich hoffe, ich hab jetzt keinen Punkt vergessen.
Das kann man alles nochmal im Podcast nachhören, wenn man sich nicht genau weiß, was Paul gesagt hat. Aber wie ist sie denn jetzt gerade?
Ja, und sie hat sich auch nicht wirklich geändert.
Was?
Ich habe für mich jetzt entschlossen, dass wenn es jetzt so heißt, dass alle für Behördengänge sowas brauchen, wenn sie Internet haben, dann muss ich es ja so oder so haben. Aber wenn es nur eine Option ist, dass man so seine Behördenbriefe empfängt, dann werde ich es lassen. Also entweder, wenn man die dann optional angeben kann, die De-Mail-Adresse oder die Mail-Adresse, dass ich die dann einfach nicht angebe. Oder wenn man eine hat, dass man dann automatisch in dem System drin ist, dass ich die dann wieder lösche.
Aber wir haben uns doch so müde gegeben, Werbung zu machen. Hat bei dir wohl nicht so gefruchtet?
Nee.
Es gibt ein tolles Gewinnspiel. Zumindest bei der Post.
Aber dann habe ich auch, glaube ich, hoffe ich jedenfalls, nicht diese AGB-Klausel, dass ich...
Würde ich erst mal nachlesen.
Das solltest du auf jeden Fall.
Also jedenfalls, als ich mich angemeldet habe, musste ich nichts ankreuzen, dass ich den AGB...
Nee, da hast du mich dran. Es gibt dieses Gewinnspiel, aber es ist sowieso in...
Na, wenn du schon vorher Kunde warst, dann hast du natürlich ihren AGB zuvor bereits zugestimmt.
Da müssen sie mich aber informieren, dass ihre AGBs geändert haben.
Ja, vielleicht haben sie es aber nicht geändert. Kann ja sein, dass die gleich geblieben sind.
Gut, dann wünschen wir viel Spaß mit ohne De-Mail, weil so richtig durchgesetzt hat sich das System eigentlich nicht. Also auch auf meiner Liste stehen immer noch die vier Punkte, die dagegen sprechen, als da wären, dass die De-Mail das so handhaben soll, dass es als Empfang gilt. Also ich habe die Mail bekommen, wenn sie beim Anbieter in meinem Postkasten liegt, die juristischen Fristen fangen an zu laufen. Ziemlich viele Leute können darauf zugreifen, zwar unter juristischen Bedingungen, aber die sind jetzt nicht so schwer einzuhalten. Die Zertifikatsvergabe zur technischen Sicherheit ist so ein bisschen so, dass ich denke, okay, das ist nicht ganz sicher. Und auch die technische Kompetenz der Anbieter von De-Mail sind eher als fragwürdig hier.
Da möchte man vor allem das Wort T-Systems hier mal einwerfen.
Es macht das nicht besser.
Du hast was vergessen, das fünfte Argument.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade fragen, abschließende Worte von Konstanze Kurz von Chaos Computer Club und Jörg Pohle von der Universität zu Berlin, aber bitte.
Nein, ich glaube, das fünfte Argument sollte man schon dazu nehmen. Also zu fragen, welchem Anbieter gibt man da seine Daten? Bei der Post als großem Adresshändler oder bei der Telekom als bekanntem Datenskandalist ist das glaube ich schon eine Frage, die sich unter 5 einsortiert. Aber wir hatten eigentlich, wir hatten als wir über die Sendung gesprochen haben auch noch einen interessanten Punkt zu dieser Namensvergabe. Das heißt jetzt De-Mail. Und dann haben wir uns gefragt, wie spricht man das eigentlich? Spricht man eine De-Mail? De-Mail? Wie spricht man das eigentlich? Und uns fiel auf, dass diese Vorsilbe ja auch in anderen deutschen Worten üblich ist. Sowas wie de-anonymisieren, de-maskieren. Und wir fanden dieses Spiel mit dem Wort eigentlich ganz interessant. So ein bisschen wie, also eben wie eine De-Mail im Gegensatz zu Gratis-Mail. Jetzt bezahlen wir die De-Mails. Und da wir jetzt aktuell so viel über Depublizieren reden, weil ja die öffentlich-rechtlichen leider so viel Inhalte aus dem Netz rausnehmen müssen, fanden wir diese diese Anwandlung irgendwie schön.
Was ich jetzt als letzte Frage noch hätte ist, jemand meinte, man könnte ja, siehst du, eine De-Mail-Adresse zulegen und dann Mails verschicken und zwar Fishing-Mails.
Ah ja, weil du dich ausweisen willst dafür, dass du Fischer bist?
Nee, eher so im Sinne von, guck mal, hier ist eine signierte De-Mail, geh mal auf das Portal und log dich ein, wir brauchen dringend deine neuen Zugangsdaten.
Ich fände das eine gute Methode, die Quote derjenigen, die dort reinfallen, könnte höher sein als im normalen Gratis-Mail-Geschäft.
Das ist tatsächlich auch der Grund, warum die Aussage, dass Spam wird darüber nicht funktionieren, nicht so stimmt. Die wissen das schon, das ist der Grund, warum sie das auf 100 versendete De-Mails pro Tag beschränken, weil sie sich natürlich darüber im Klaren sind, dass sowas wie Phishing, so was wie Malware auf dem Rechner...
Ja, man muss natürlich auch mal daran... Also, dass das generisch zu die Adresse zu berechnen ist, das ist ein Fakt. Nur die Frage, wie benutzt wird das einander. Man muss aber, glaube ich, ein paar Beispiele, die wir bisher noch nicht hatten, dazu nehmen. Also, das ist nicht nur immer Vornahme, Nachname, sondern das kann durchaus auch das, was im Ausweis steht sein. Also etwa ein Künstlernname oder ein Ordensname, auch das ist möglich. Also, die haben alle Möglichkeiten, die auf deutschen Ausweisen stehen können. Dazu hier noch die juristische Person. Das kann man eben schön generieren.
Na ja, da steht uns also einiges bevor. Tja, das war es also zur De-Mail. Ich fürchte, die hat heute nicht Fans dazu gewonnen. Würde mich zumindest ein bisschen wundern. Diese Sendung möchte ich dann sozusagen hiermit abschließen. Und den beiden Experten vor Ort recht herzlichen Dank sagen, dass ihr da wart. Und euch für eure Anrufe. Aber es ist ja auch traditionell so, dass dieser letzte Mittwoch im Monat dazu benutzt wird, dass der Chaos Computer Club Werbung für Dinge macht, die so passieren bei dem. Also manchmal passiert sonntags im Club was. Quatsch, sonntags, Donnerstags, da kann man hinkommen. Steht da was an?
Nee, wir planen derzeit keinen Datengarten. Aber wir haben da immer diese große Veranstaltung zum Jahresende.
Ich hab mich schon gefragt, ob die stattfindet, weil hätte man nicht um diese Zeit schon was hören sollen.
Ja, also wir bereiten derzeit den Call for Papers vor. Das heißt, wir werden in sehr kurzer Zeit die ersten Einreichungen für den Chaos Communication Congress zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr entgegennehmen. Und ich darf auch noch hinweisen auf die Veranstaltung Datenspuren in Dresden, die wieder stattfindet. Also da im Chaos Computer Club sind immer viele Aktivitäten zu beobachten. Und wer noch nicht unsere elf Forderungen für eine gesunde, gute, zukunftsträchtige Netzpolitik gelesen hat, der sollte mal auf ccc.de klicken, denn ich glaube, es lohnt sich da mal.
Also ihr macht doch wirklich jeden Scheiß mit, oder? Netzthesen schreiben?
Das sind nicht Thesen, das sind Forderungen.
Entschuldigung. Aber noch mal genauer zu Datenspuren. Wann?
Oh, ich hatte das Datum jetzt gar nicht. Jörg hat den Recherch. Jörg muss nachgucken, ist schuld.
Okay, dann erzähl doch währenddessen, was da passiert.
Die Datenspuren sind insofern immer ein sehr interessantes Symposium, weil das so eine kleine, schöne Location in Dresden ist, wo man noch ein bisschen mehr als beim Kongress diese Vorlesungshafte verliert. Man kann also viel Hands-on, viel Workshops, aber man kann vor allen Dingen gut debattieren, weil das sind immer keine Tausende, sondern hunderte Leute, ein bisschen kleiner. Das ist übrigens komplett kostenlos. Und da läuft gerade auch der Call for Papers, also wer sich da gerne wieder eine Idee hat, das ist vom 16. bis 17. Oktober, also ein schönes Wochenende im wunderbaren Dresden, was übrigens immer eine Reise wert ist.
Noch eine Weile hin. Okay, aber wisst ihr Bescheid, diese Sendung gibt es als Podcast, demnächst gleich sofort auf fritz.de, später dann auch noch auf chaosradio.de. Könnt ihr euch dort ziehen. Wir übergeben jetzt hier an zwei neue Leute, die ein Nerdfight machen und zwar kommen jetzt Huerto Rick Ostler und Max West Weiss und bringen mit Strange Games, Funky Sings, Legendary, Rock'n'RnB und noch viele mehr. Ich bin wirklich gespannt, was das wird und wünsche euch mit den beiden auf jeden Fall eine schöne Nacht und sage Tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal. Macht immer schön eure Pack-Ups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.
Ich hab auch schon zehn Jahre her, Export 2000, es ist nicht mehr ganz so aktuell.